once upon a time good boys and girls
could turn on their TV sets and see
fresh original characters and storylines
nowadays it seems like any old story
that has a trace of the macabre the
supernatural to it is being turned into
a TV drama the formula is simple find a
classic yarn public domain of course so
you don't have to pay anyone for the
rights then transpose it to the present
day and film it in some city that offers
huge tax breaks just look at this new
show Sleepy Hollow which takes
Washington Irving's gullible cowardly
beanpole Ichabod Crane and turns him
into a hunky time-traveling crime
fighter in present-day North Carolina
brought to you by the same writers who
thought they could improve star trek by
adding the barona paradoxes the most
nefarious fantasy drama is undoubtedly
ABC Disney's once upon a time this
series populates a modern-day city with
characters and plot devices swipe from
Beauty and the Beast Peter Pan Pinocchio
Cinderella Sleeping Beauty and now
there's a whole spin-off series set in a
Lewis Carroll Wonderland verse what's
particularly insidious about once upon a
time is it the source material is not
the gory creepy classic stories
collected by Hans Christian Andersen or
the Brothers Grimm it's the pop-culture
versions of these stories that we know
from the films made by the house of
mouse but once upon a time verse isn't
the land of fairy tales it's Disneyland
the show makes coy references to Tron in
101 Dalmatians in case you missed this
building fast crossover universes out of
pre-existing intellectual properties
it's a classic Disney move oh it would
take a hero as powerful as Hercules to
bring down this man
ended media i drugged oh I forgot
they've got him too what do you think
about fairy tales in popular culture let
me know in the comments and subscribe to
the wire channel